dimanche soir M6 diffusé en prime une
enquête de son interdite qui traitait de
la transidentité des transgenres et des
transitions ce numéro fait énormément
parler depuis avec des questions
difficiles est-il normal que les
transitions soient remboursées les
mineurs peuvent-ils être autorisés à
faire une transition depuis dimanche on
voit énormément de réactions sur les
réseaux on va revenir sur les extraits
plus forts les plus forts de zone
interdites on a d'abord vu Jacky c'est à
59 ans qu'elle a commencé sa transition
hormone chirurgie cela fait des
décennies qu'elle rêvaient de ça pour
enfin vivre en accord avec son genre
regardez merci Michel Jackie a débuté sa
transition en prenant des hormones à
l'âge de 59 ans
d'opérer du visage et des corps de
vocales une opération qui a
malheureusement échoué Jacquie n'a pas
pu changer de genre avant et pourtant
elle le souhaitait depuis l'adolescence
[Musique]
c'est plus possible je veux plus vivre
comme ça sinon je vais finir comment
enfin tu finiras ma vie oh non mais
Jacky a fini par changer de genre il
était essentiel pour elle de se faire
opérer des parties génitales elle a subi
à l'âge de 63 ans ce que l'on appelle
une vaginoplastie
elle a commencé cette transition à 59
ans alors ce qui pose problème merci en
tout cas Nina d'être avec nous on
l'adore
ce qui pose problème c'est que c'est
remboursé transformation par la Sécurité
sociale c'est ça qui a fait le plus
polémique gilbertez absolument alors la
polémique est double si je puis dire
parce que depuis 2009 la transidentité
c'est plus une pathologie entre
guillemets c'est plus une maladie et ça
heureusement que c'est plus considéré
comme une maladie mais paradoxalement ce
n'est plus une maladie ça continue à
être remboursé comme une affection
longue durée cercle les gens sont
remboursés à 100% sauf pour les
dépassements d'honoraires et ça ça a
choqué des gens qui disent puisque ce
n'est plus une maladie qu'entre
guillemets certains le considèrent comme
un choix ça ne devrait pas être
remboursé mais voilà je prends pas parti
je fixe
moi je pense que ce qui est pas normal
c'est les pathologies qui sont pas
remboursées mais c'est pas c'est pas que
nous on est les opérations bon c'est moi
personnellement j'ai eu mes opérations
remboursées à part le nez c'est mon
copain qui me l'a payé parce que là la
rhinoplastine prend ne rend pas en
charge dans la transition à peu près sur
toutes les opérations ça rembourse mais
une vaginoplastie c'est entre 15 et 20
000 euros de remboursé par la Sécurité
sociale et une féminisation faciale la
totale on doit être pas loin aussi
est-ce qu'il y en a que ça choque que
c'est remboursé par la sécurité dites la
vérité ici Daniel oui parce qu'en fait
c'est pas tellement le prix mais c'est
un pour moi alors après je peux me
tromper c'est un choix déterminé je suis
ravi que vous soyez mieux dans votre
peau et c'est formidable mais voilà je
trouve ça un peu choquant parce que j'ai
des exemples très précis dont je
parlerai pas ici de choses qui ne sont
pas remboursées et qui ont été pour ma
mère mais vraiment très salutaire qui ne
sont pas remboursés par
la population c'est les 30 en France
sont entre 20000 et 30000 donc ça
représente absolument rien et par
exemple je te rappelle que par exemple
des cures thermales sont remboursés par
la sécu il y a des choses qui sont
encore plus aberrantes et juste pour
préciser c'est important vraiment de le
dire que ce n'est pas un choix voilà
c'est c'est
identité
mais moi de ce que j'envoie j'ai
l'impression que c'est un choix pour
aller mieux et c'est formidable sont les
les mieux placés pour t'en parler est-ce
que c'est un choix parce que moi j'ai
toujours ressenti que j'étais pas né
dans le bon corps donc je pense non
c'est pas un choix après je suis
d'accord sur ce que vous dites aussi que
il y en a qui voilà qui qui font
peut-être pas ça pour les bonnes raisons
mais c'est à dire en tout cas ça j'ai
non non j'ai pas dit ça mais parce que
vous avez dit question c'est que là dans
le dans zone interdite c'était
intéressant parce que j'ai l'impression
que de plus en plus il y a des comment
ça s'appelle la des transitions
par la sécurité
très à charge et j'ai pas aimé du tout
ce zones on va voir un deuxième un
deuxième extrait ces hormones peuvent
pourtant avoir des effets secondaires
assez importants de l'interdit tu as
suivi Élie qui après avoir commencé une
transition avait fait marche arrière
regardez
en général ce que je lui dis c'est que
j'ai une expérience de transition j'ai
fait une transition en assez jeune âge
et je me suis rendu compte au bout d'un
certain temps que c'était pas ce qui me
convenait je me perçois pas comme une
femme et je me vois pas devenir une
femme et donc j'ai commencé à être dans
ce questionnement de mais pourquoi
est-ce que je me sens différente des
autres filles autour de moi j'ai
commencé à vraiment rejeter mon corps
parce que je savais qu'il y avait une
possibilité de le changer ce mal-être il
n'était pas en moi avant ma démarche est
pas du tout de refaire le parcours dans
l'autre sens c'est plutôt d'arrêter ces
changements là d'arrêter c'est dans la
recherche de quelque chose d'autre et de
juste accepter les choses telles
qu'elles sont maintenant important c'est
de lâcher prise et de simplement d'être
c'est ça m'a des transitions alors je
voudrais dire sur les cures thermales
elles sont remboursées quand il y a une
pathologie sinon
psychologique
psychologique c'est aussi remboursé
souvent par la sécu finalement la
transition c'est aussi la suite d'un
suivi psychologique par rapport à des
personnes qui sont en souffrance
a décrédibilisé les personnes trans
enfin c'était c'était pas à faire quoi
alors il y a un extrait qui a fait plus
parlé que les autres ils ont suivi
Cédric pour comprendre comment se passer
les prises d'hormones vous allez voir
que c'est très simple avec des
infirmiers que c'est entièrement pris en
charge et ça en fait on vient d'en
parler qui est le plus problématique
pour les téléspectateurs regardez
deux fois par mois il a un rendez-vous
un manque
[Applaudissements]
le cabinet infirmier pour son injection
de testostérone
bonjour
un traitement qu'il devra suivre à vie
tous les 13 à 15 jours tu as des effets
secondaires il y a forcément des effets
secondaires les poils la voix et tout ça
en fait les premiers effets bah c'est
d'abord la voix si elle est très
rapidement honnêtement et au bout de 9
mois si déjà six mois ça se stabilisait
au bout de 9 mois c'était bon c'était ma
voix définitive pour ces consultations
ces médicaments et même certaines
chirurgies cédric est couvert à 100% par
l'Assurance maladie au titre de la Ld
l'affection longue durée c'est ça c'est
ça mais notre système de santé et puis
après le truc c'est que si c'est pas
remboursé bah c'est tellement cher il y
en a ils ont pas les moyens et tout bah
que après ça
[Musique]
ils peuvent enfin mettre fin à leur jour
c'est compliqué il faut quand même
rappeler que tout ça le but c'est de
sauver des gens en fait c'est pas de
faire plaisir c'est pareil encore une
fois le seul but c'est de sauver une
partie de la population qui est en
danger toi tu te sens vraiment mieux toi
Nina ah bah oui moi ça fait 6 ans c'est
je suis heureux j'ai tout fait j'ai et
puis si ça avait pas été remboursé
t'aurais pas pu le faire bah j'aurais
pas pu le faire enfin aussi vite entre
guillemets parce que on tient une chose
qui est vrai dans dans le reportage
c'est que oui par contre c'est très long
et ça alors il y a un pays où c'est très
facile c'est la Suède en Suède ils
avaient glande aussi et bah la Suède
regarde dans certains pays des choses
sont encore plus libre et simple que
chez nous en Suède ils avaient tout fait
pour faciliter les transitions même chez
les adolescents
c'est des équipes dédiées au changement
de genre y compris chez les plus jeunes
les médecins ont longtemps été autorisés
à bloquer la puberté des enfants dès
l'âge de 12 ans
cette grande facilité d'accès au
traitement a conduit à une explosion des
demandes de transition une étude montre
que les personnes transgenres de moins
de 25 ans était devenu 160 fois plus
nombreuses en 20 ans et toujours en 2019
dans la presse des révélations vont
choquer le pays
l'équipe du service de psychiatrie
pédiatrique de l'hôpital carolinska a
procédé à l'ablation des saints de
jeunes filles
âgées d’appen 14 ans
je pense que qu'il faut vraiment laisser
tranquille avant 18 ans pour déjà de
toute façon c'est
sans doute pour ça aussi qu'il va y
avoir de plus en plus de des transitions
parce qu'on fait de plus en plus la
France et je pense moi j'ai pas trouvé
que c'était à charge alors peut-être
j'ai entendu ce que j'avais envie
d'entendre donc maintenant j'ai trouvé
que c'était assez enfin voilà que j'ai
appris plein de choses et ça a changé
mon regard sur certaines choses et moi
je suis toujours heureuse quand je vois
quelqu'un de rue ça bien sûr alors en
revanche
pour les mineurs
c'était trop facile on les encourager
presque moi j'ai des pains
non mais c'est vrai c'est c'est un
danger il faut faire alors
au niveau de l'âge on est bien en train
de
Tik Tok n'hésite pas à te montrer des
photos de toi avant ta transformation
est-ce que tu m'autorises à ce qu'on
diffuse cette photo
que je regardais la transformation elle
est incroyable
moi quand j'étais petit ça c'était moi
un peu plus jeune pendant l'adolescence
voilà on commençait un peu à mettre du
rose on commençait un peu à se chercher
c'était moi un tout petit peu avant ma
transition donc vous voyez je me
maquillais je faisais le teint je me
faisais les sourcils ça c'était moi donc
bah pendant ma transition au tout début
donc vous voyez je commence à laisser
pousser mes cheveux je me maquillais je
commençais à être un peu plus féminine
et voilà c'est temps après après une
fémination faciale une augmentation
mammaire et un changement de sexe mais
voilà alors on va voir ce qu'on pense
qu'elle a été spectateurs sur la
sécurité sociale voilà certaines
opérations comprenez-vous que certaines
opérations soient remboursées non à 87%
sur l'étrange genre
un accident de la réponse un accident de
voiture par exemple c'est normal
c'est les
pathologies qui voilà en tout cas 80
voilà
86%, 80%